ذكرت بانه ب 20 24 سيكون هناك رئيسا
جمهوريا هل هذا مبني على نتائج همم
الانتخابات النصفيه في الكونجرس ام انه
مجرد توقع منك
واغلبها والاكثر مصداقيه فيها تشير الى ان
الجو بارد سيعاني صعوبات جمه في سعيه
للفوز بل اننا قرانا استطاعات قبل بدعه
شهور على نيويورك تايمز المعروفه بانها
احد اصوات الديمقراطيين تشيروا الى ان
هناك اغلبيه ديمقراطيه لا ترغب في رؤيه جو
بيد يترشح من جديد لصداق الانتخابات
الرئاسيه عام 2024 قولوا القياده في الحزب
الديمقراطيه عمليا غير موافقه على ان
يتقدم بعض مجددا كل هذه العوامل السلبيه
للرئيس بعدل وتدفع الحسبه لديمقراطي للنظر
الى وضعه والبحث عن المرشح الاقوى من ضمن
هاتيه فحتى نائبه الرئيس كماله هاريس لا
تحظى بدعم كاف واداءها حتى الان لا يشجعوا
على ان تكون مرشحه محتمله من الحزب
الديمقتي في انتخابات 2024 والاسوء انهم
من احد برز اسمه من ضمن صفوفهم يمكن ان
يكون جديدا بقوه بالترشحها